with Summer has just been so [__]
awful to me another day another Tom
scandable it was nice to take a year off
and sort of uh do some self-reflection
get in touch with ourselves with each
other
Bravo cameras are back up and rolling
for season 10 capturing the aftermath of
his breakup with long-time partner and
co-star Ariana Maddox but a source tells
ET that Tom's threatened to stop filming
you know in relationships you see when
people go to the dark side the reason
well The Insider says it surrounds new
scenes with Raquel Levis Tom admitted to
having an affair with her and they are
now filming as a couple and this year I
kind of did a deep dive and really
opened myself up and experienced new
things being single The Source claims he
thought a scene they filmed made him
look bad and he wanted it re-shot but
the show's producers weren't having it
and felt they got what they needed I'm
just trying to live my life and I'm
sorry if that offends people now Tom and
OG pump rule star is saying he won't
film however a source close to the
production tells E.T Tom is expected to
film again later this week
ET has reached out to Bravo for comment
if you're in Orange County okay and
you're planning on seeing Tom Sandoval
on the most extra tonight don't forget
to bring the tomatoes and the Cabbage
okay meanwhile in the pump verse another
source reveals sweet tea Tom and Ariana
are telling friends they're totally done
it's scary it's a scary world and the
sexually explicit video that allegedly
started it all Raquel now claims it was
recorded without her consent she sent
several members of the cast a legal
warning to delete it plus a blast from
the past People magazine was first to
report that former cast member Kristen
dally and Tom's ex-girlfriend is in
talks to return
et's learned Kristen wants to support
Ariana in whatever way Ariana wants her
to I stand Ariana this is in real time
I love you so much I love you as for the
matriarch it's okay Lisa Vanderpump is
set for Watch What Happens live with
former pum bartender Jax Taylor on
dagbrae clubhouse comeback his tweet on
Tuesday see you soon how would you
describe the vibe of season 10. someone
who's seeing you know marriages break up
we've seen you know people opening
businesses it's always been about a
group of people that's so inextricably
entwined and love each other but also so
volatile there's a lot of still
stop Brewing I mean that's you know
there's quick out the gate these guys
[Music]
thank you